to make sure this is uh this is good
what a delight to be here thank you very
much uh uh for organizing uh such a
great turnout and a very useful and
fruitful event
I want to start by congratulating you on
the theme that you have chosen for this
Summit cutting crime and building
confidence is exactly what is needed
and the way to ensure public confidence
in the police is to focus on getting the
basics right what I call Common Sense
policing the kind of policing that the
law-abiding patriotic majority of
British people deserve and expects
no politically correct distractions just
good old-fashioned policing with a
Relentless focus on making our streets
homes and transport networks safer
responding to all burglaries tackling
anti-social Behavior and the horrendous
trade in illegal drugs
and supporting victims
I know that if police officers are
properly empowered to do the job for
which they signed up they can really
drive down crime
the government wants to see reductions
in homicide other serious violence and
neighborhood crime and I know it's
possible
our best police officers are simply put
the finest in the world in my time in
office I've witnessed excellence
from policing when it comes to whether
it's her majesty the Queen's funeral to
the response to the disorder in
Leicester
and I want that Excellence to come as
standard
now I know what good policing looks like
because I've seen it in action
the county lines and project Adder
programs are making huge inroads into
defeating the scourge of illegal drugs
tackling Supply and disrupting gangs
almost 3 000 county lines have been
closed down since 2019 putting dealers
out of business and helping huge numbers
escape the clutches of drug addiction
and exploitation
that's work that you achieved and that
you led
the work of the Milton Keynes and Thames
Valley police is another great example
there the police are ensuring that those
caught carrying knives face Swift and
certain consequences that they are
arrested charged and remanded in custody
more forces should follow this example
to send the clear message that carrying
weapons on our streets will not be
tolerated
pccs have a major role to play in
helping to coordinate local multi-agency
work in support of all these objectives
things can be turned around for the
better in a comparatively short period
of time
superb leadership from Chief Constable
Stephen Watson has made a big difference
to Greater Manchester police they are
responding there far faster to emergency
calls and the number of open
investigations has halved since 2021
he put and how did he do it he put more
Bobbies on the beat pursued every crime
made excellent use of stop and search
and insisted that officers were smartly
turned out with polished boots
he rejects woke policing and embraced a
Back to Basics approach
for me that is excellence in policing
and if we are to maintain a world-class
reputation for policing we need to be
willing to learn from others share best
practice and continuously look to
improve
I'm really grateful that Chief Council
Watson has offered to share what he has
learned from turning greater Manchester
police around
everyone should pay close attention
there are six forces that still remain
in engage
and I expect to see them make the
necessary improvements quickly working
constructively with the inspectorate
they have my full support and I want
them to succeed
but I'm also very concerned that more
than half of the forces inspected by the
inspectorate in the recent inspection
cycle have received poor grades for how
they respond to the public and nearly
half for how well they investigate crime
this is fundamental
policing is a public service Above All
Else
just last week the inspector released
their sobering report into vetting and
Corruption
far too often standards have not been
high enough
and Despicable people have been able to
enter and remain in the police
policing is a job that attracts the very
best of us the vast majority of police
officers are exemplary citizens
but anyone who might want to hurt others
simply must not be able to join and
those who are otherwise ill-suited need
to be weeded out and quickly
the report finds that previous warnings
have not been acted upon
that is unacceptable
I therefore welcome the fact that the
mpcc has promised that Chiefs will do
everything necessary to deliver on the
recommendations of the report
essential that we get both vetting and
recruitment right which means Chief
officers must draw from the best and
widest pool of talent possible as well
as ensuring consistent and high
standards in the vetting process
I also welcome the College of policing's
proposals for change which follow a full
independent review of progression and
development to chief officer ranks
these measures
once implemented will increase
transparency and open up access to
senior level development
the government has provided significant
investment to the College of policing to
create a national Leadership Center it
will develop standards and a leadership
development framework for all ranks
the interim findings of baroness Casey's
review set out unequivocal failures by
the Metropolitan Police Service who did
not act effectively on allegations of
serious misconduct in particular
instances of sexual misconduct and
discrimination
I know that Sir Mark Rowley shares my
view that this is utterly appalling and
intolerable
that's why he's created a new
anti-corruption and abuse command
recognizing that change must come from
within the Metropolitan Police Service
but I will not hesitate to act either
I recently announced an internal review
Into the effectiveness of the police
officer dismissals process for example
and I'm very keen to get your views as
we go through that process
we have some big challenges when it
comes to cutting crime
I am deeply concerned about the levels
of homicide
while the number of murders that took
place in the first six months of 2022
suggests the numbers are falling a
reduction will only be possible if the
whole policing system works closely
together
the College of policing's homicide
prevention framework which launched last
month was developed with the mpcc and
the inspectorate and is a great example
of collaborative working and the sharing
of expertise
meanwhile I am making 130 million pounds
available this financial year to tackle
serious violence including 64 million
pounds for our network of 20 violence
reduction units
from January the series of violence Duty
will place a duty on local Partners to
work together to tackle the root causes
of violence
and as I said at the Conservative Party
Conference broken windows matter
there is no such thing as petty crime
any tolerance of low-level disorder and
crime will only beget more serious crime
you all know this
I'm sure of it
and that's why it's absolutely correct
that all forces have agreed to send an
officer to the scene of every
residential burglary
I thank you for that commitment every
kind of neighborhood crime needs to be
tackled robustly if we are to ensure
public confidence and Trust
the safer streets fund has supported
interventions
addressing local needs across England
and Wales which is why the government
announced a further 50 million pounds
earlier this year to support 111
projects
I also want to see a major Improvement
in the way the whole of the Criminal
Justice System deals with rape
it is promising that more victims of
sexual offenses are coming forward to
report crimes to the police and that
more suspects are being charged
but we still have a very long way to go
as a society too often we have failed
the victims of sexual violence and that
cannot continue
operations ceteria is an Innovative and
ambitious program supported by the home
office which is bringing together
Frontline policing the crown prosecution
service and academic expertise to
transform the response to rape
and The New National operating models
being developed by the program will from
June of next year support your police
forces in delivering a sustainable shift
in the way that rape is investigated
officers need to be and will be better
equipped to build strong cases and to
focus on the behavior of the suspect
rather than subjective assessments of a
victim's credibility
even in Somerset the pioneering force in
operation ceteria have reported that
charge rates have tripled since they
began the pilot and arrests are twice as
high
policing must seize the opportunities
presented by operation ceteria to
further improve your response to rape
the final report by the independent
inquiry into child sexual abuse
published last month shows how endemic
these unspeakable crimes are
the first-hand accounts of the terrible
abuse endured by children and how badly
they were let down by those who should
have protected them are truly shocking
this report has redoubled my
determination to do all of my power to
end the scourge of child sexual abuse
along with the majority the overwhelming
majority of the public I am disgusted
that misplaced cultural and political
sensitivities in places like Manchester
Rotherham and Telford got in the way
got in the way and stopped the
authorities from tackling Wicked
grooming gangs praying on vulnerable
children
we will drive radical change
the home office will take whatever
action is available to us to make our
communities safer and to protect our
children
in Rochdale the two foreign Nationals
who were members of that terrible
grooming gang were deported
other members of the group were deprived
of their British nationality and the
home office remains absolutely committed
to deporting these individuals where the
law allows it
and this is not just a matter for the
police it's a matter for all of us the
law-abiding majority but it's right that
the inspectorate is inspecting the
police response to grooming gangs
as Home Secretary I'll ensure that there
are no safe spaces for rapists
pedophiles domestic abusers grooming
gangs burglars or criminals of any kind
those convicted particularly repeat and
sexual offenders should expect longer
sentences
and I will talk honestly and
unapologetically about crime which is
never Justified and which needs to be
investigated and rooted out fearlessly
our police officers
your police officer's time is precious
and the public want the police to be
tackling crime not debating gender on
Twitter
I've asked my officials to revisit the
issue of non-crime hate incidents as a
first step as I want to be sure that we
are allowing you to prioritize your time
and your energy to deal with the threats
to people and their property
underpinning all of this is transparency
and accountability
we must not shy away from being open and
honest with the public about performance
strip search is one of the most
intrusive powers that you have
at your disposal
there is a grim reality that many of you
in this room will recognize
many criminals will stop at nothing to
evade detection
sometimes people may carry items that
pose a danger to themselves or others
concealed on them
strip search is therefore necessary
and an essential power and one that this
government supports the police to use to
protect the public and to fight crime
however any strip search must be carried
out professionally respectfully and
lawfully with full consideration of the
welfare and dignity of the person being
searched particularly if they're a child
so
I'm on your side
I want us all to pull together in the
same direction and I will do everything
in my power to support you and to back
you
officers and staff
show remarkable and inspirational
commitment to keeping the public safe in
the face of danger
detectives do extraordinary work to
ensure that we can put criminals Behind
Bars
so I cannot help but feel a deep sense
of gratitude and pride when officers and
staff have their bravery and commitment
formally recognized through medals
honors and awards
however I recognize that this only
represents a fraction of the outstanding
actions taken every day every hour every
minute
by our police across the country
I want to ensure that the amazing job
that you do is recognized in full
and we are committed through the police
Covenant to ensuring that this is done
correctly
I'm committed to supporting you in using
your powers without fear or favor to
keep our streets and to keep our people
safe
under my watch you will have my full
backing to use stop and search which is
a vital tool in the fight against Crime
since 2019 the government has been
making it easier for you to use stop and
search
by relaxing restrictions on Section 60
powers used in anticipation of violence
and empowering you to stop and challenge
no knife carriers through serious
violence reduction orders
every knife seized through stop and
search
is a potential life saved
in the 12 months to March of this year
you removed around 14
900 weapons and firearms from our
streets through stop and search and made
almost 67 000 arrests following a stop
and so to those who try to undermine
your use of stop and search or question
your legitimate use of investigatory
powers or your use of force which leads
to the prevention of crime I say this
our police are working to keep you safe
to keep your children safe to save lives
let them do their work
so it's only right that you can stand
firm against criminals rather than
listening to those who would denigrate
your work or use data selectively to
undermine your credibility
on a daily basis our police officers put
themselves In Harm's Way to protect
every single one of us
taser is a vital tactical option
I saw how vital this can be when I
visited Thames Valley police to observe
firearms training
and in March 2020 the government gave
more than 6 million pounds to forces to
purchase over 7 000 devices increasing
the number of officers who are trained
in and have a taser
in August 2020 we approved the use of
the taser 7 a more accurate and
effective device for policing and in
March we approved the use of taser by
specially trained special constables
I'm committed to ensuring that you have
access to tasers wherever appropriate
of course it's not just violent
criminals on our streets that we are
determined to stop
I also want to see more fraudsters
caught and brought to Justice
and I'm sure that's an ambition that we
all share here
that's why the government is allocating
a further 400 million pounds over the
next three years for tackling economic
crime including fraud
by March 2025 over 330 new officers
dedicated to this work will have been
recruited into the city of London Police
the regional organized crime units and
the National Crime agency
we will replace the current action fraud
system with a new and improved service
and we will increase intelligence
capabilities at the NCA and the National
Security Community to identify and
disrupt the most harmful criminals and
serious organized criminal gangs
and we are making sure that the biggest
technology companies are doing
everything they can to prevent online
fraud through our world-leading Online
safety bill